alright hey everyone this is order here
I'm here tonight with Alan on the audio
what's up and we thought it'd be cool to
heed questions from you guys and try
that out with you guys so ask us
anything about growth healing
spirituality the future the next world a
social engineering and stuff year moved
about stuff you feel moved about and
we're here and let's let's explore
[Music]
why do you pick those topics as the
people are gonna start viewing and
asking questions will take a little bit
so why those topics I guess I feel close
to them I feel like I have a
relationship with them and experience
pondering them that's why yeah any other
topics come to mind Alan you know those
were all exceptional yeah all right
flowering of consciousness I wonder if
we're gonna see a big red or Angela or
Marcos aha
[Music]
just let our viewers know that uh we are
fielding questions in the comments
that's right all right we gaining our
viewership right now so ask away my goal
my goal Allen would be to find a flow
state with our viewers where we can
start to really shine and serve up
something nutritious yes
something nutritious for what for the
Soul hmm for the being behind the
eyeballs and what would that nutrition
do for the person re-energize bring them
back up light their candle provide
catharsis a sense of richness or
sweetness or healing or release or
energizing something real you know
something that people are looking for
whether they know it or not so calling
in those people calling in the people
who could use what we can provide here
tonight yes
how many viewers we got we have people
jumping in and out right now back to one
right now all right let us know your
thoughts if you have any questions for
Laurie let us know
[Music]
I'll start you off with the question
yeah what's up please
[Music]
what are the
what are thee I don't believe that's a
valid English sentence question what is
the what are the things that need to be
done in order to flower consciousness to
the new world it starts with the
individual people need to love
themselves for real enough to be alone
and not suffer people need to get in
touch with themselves with their true
desires with their emotional pain
with their soulful calling is it it
starts with the individual an integrated
individual radiates and attracts harmony
and good stuff
so everyone is a player everyone matters
every collection of cells and history
has dirt to make a flower with
and so tonight I would love to address
individuals is processes their life
process their evolutionary process their
process of meaning their process of
suffering their process of
transformation process of inquiry I
would love to sit with it for people
how many viewers we got bounced up to
two in the back for one all right
doubling up as Ron Vargas would say
we're on track we're gonna be rich baby
shout out Ron Vargas calling on calling
in Ron Vargas if he happens to show up
they're teaching us so much about life
and all the technical skills needed to
do this the original Vargas the original
tech man
the original simulation duo man
n'stuff
we love you we do
yeah you've got me too well I can ask
you a question Alan yeah I'm just gonna
say you also got me to go deeper into
myself in my shadow which has been
really interesting recently I forgot
that all of that stuff even existed yeah
yeah and then all of a sudden that
starts coming up in different ways some
of the deepest parts gotta take care of
it ten of those parts of the garden yeah
what is your question
how the heck are we going to be
captivating talking about this stuff
well
this is our practice this is our
training grounds for becoming more and
more captivating at doing these
processes
how do you want to be captivating on
doing this I want to find a flow state I
want to become comfortable with the
people that's right
I wanna
yeah
I do too that's always ideal
flow state
I don't think there's anything else as
meaningful in this life for me as I
guess you could say teaching people yeah
it energizes me
you told me the same yep
want our gifts to register but for now
we're just a couple of lonely schmoes in
this moment yeah it's like might as well
start raining living early let me see if
I can add that graphic quick that
animation no way no well it's probably a
setting butter all right we should get
we should have that setup in the future
yeah for moments like these we're facing
a rain our a rain moment rain period and
one of the dunking animations just takes
our guests and dunks on my head or your
head pretty much or maybe a flower
blossoming animation that happens on the
show this is true
I have a feeling that the one person
watching could be a could be a member of
fam really no it's just a feeling that I
had
okay I think you're gonna I thought it
is gonna be like Ori
first comment are you high AF a family
member like Boris or your mother
mm-hm watching Rory the evening of
questions Boris and Bella Alan's rents
parents yeah
fam mom and uncle excuse me love them
I've met them both had the pleasure I've
gone to Safeway with Boris I've
connected with him in my home Alan's
uncle I have
yeah connected with Alan's mother Bella
on skype and here in San Jose a Boris's
apartments when she visited this past
month and so you could say I'm pretty
much besties with Alan's fam I'm in
there and Alan has chopped it up with my
family as well it's been fun and things
are good
we're in the web's literally in this
moment we're in the web the most dynamic
thing here is this stupid light hey I'm
just saying man no one cares about us
Alan hey what's up another viewer if you
have any questions for Lori if you have
any questions for Ori let us know we are
here we come in peace we're sober
we're never not I know
which is so funny
questions questions questions questions
questions questions questions questions
questions questions questions questions
questions questions questions questions
questions questions questions give us
their questions give us their questions
give us their questions give us their
questions give us the questions give us
their questions give us the questions
good questions given some questions
courage of course sir
let's see yeah I have never been so
hungry for a question in my life see how
that sounds
[Music]
oh okay I'm with it say about this one
[Music]
let us know your questions
let us know your questions yeah we love
you know we're gonna get in flow
spirituality let's go let us know your
questions yeah feeling kind of nervous
I know y'all heard this we probably got
one viewer didn't cooked like a skewer
or Corey Brewer that's a ballplayer if
you knew her or him getting stem from
the music in of rain
look I'm insane look I've been came
through to our living room where me and
Alan are making music
just love flow like water yo right up in
my class yeah you know we gorgeous came
seven hour fast yeah you heard that
right yeah you had that right Alan
drinking his sprite
alright we gonna take your questions all
night I'm all white but I like all
varieties of humans as we bump into the
music as we flow and like some fluid
Jewish is what my family is look I
didn't came through children with my boy
and we get a suite like it's Chips Ahoy
play like a toy huh that's what it is
boy boy I just felt a chill in my neck
is someone watching the video yeah first
letter of my name is oh [ __ ] I'm in the
zone I'm about to go and throw some
lyrics on this [ __ ] video Island
chillin with the bro was good man in my
fo yeah you know it's all good well yeah
no killing it go yeah you know behind
the TriCaster
we're about to skip to the next trap a
as a dope one as a dope one Alan
yeah uh-huh uh-huh look we're doing this
bro huh it meant it was meant to happen
apparently Aaron Lee look thought we was
gonna take some questions but we did it
so far this is really hard
hey and I'm a little shy but it's not a
question
Hey another viewer what's up were taking
questions for or if you'd like to hello
hello another viewer I'm an open book
for life itself for anything meaningful
to anyone who is conscious and breathing
this is my this is my method to try to
be like Sadhguru this is my first step
I feel you guys I feel the viewers I
feel I balls it might be one it might
have been one but I feel it it feels
like pressure and I want to meet it want
to interact Oh Oh Allen just stood up
you getting on this
well we're yeah there's though the
camera is a little off but yeah we're
2025 in right now 25 minutes
yeah damn that was fast I know what
should we do we can also do another one
of these maybe at not 10:00 p.m. is this
Logan Paul is that what you think this
is Logan and Jake Paul I'm appalled
we can yeah we can also try you in a
different hours okay yeah let's uh how
much longer do you want to try and see
if we can get any questions five minutes
I see if we have another same
yeah it's really important to do a first
principle of understanding of how to
flower consciousness so if the first
principle is you said know thyself right
mm-hm
and then it's accept thyself mm-hmm and
then it's be the creator yes okay what's
wrong with that what was that experience
like for you when you knew you first
learned about yourself accepted yourself
and then became the creator
epic
it was epic
how did you do it hey hey thanks for
tuning in if you ever get any questions
let us know or he's fielding questions
hello hello thanks for tuning in
how did you know that you hadn't known
you had found yourself when you were
studying to find yourself to know
yourself
it's like re occurrence every day you
know yeah how about you yeah it is
definitely a moment-to-moment learning
simulation as you like to put it yeah
it's kind of a meditation an 82 year
meditation
that's a really good question though is
uh you enter into the learning
simulation you have to remember who you
are and why you came mmm yes totally
totally bro
I like this stuff good it's great
practice it's just uh maybe we try it
not 10:00 p.m. Pacific time next time
yeah
movie tried during the day maybe people
tune in more true
hey guys thanks for tuning in we really
appreciate you
orys fielding questions right now about
all things growth evolution healing
spirituality if you have any questions
please ask away he would love to answer
them for you
we have more people watching now so
trying to get a mask alright
looking forward to your question
forward to your question
anything lay it on me
people
how did you do the process of accepting
well every moment bro every moment I'm
just like oh what if I like this is
happening and then I just like totally
ride that wave you know okay what's next
that's scary and like yeah so you're
surfing the waves of the learning
simulation yeah you you feel that it's
happening for you and for us all I feel
like it can I feel like it's available
to be unconditionally loving if we like
take it if we like just decide to be
totally intentional yeah and then how do
you become the creator how do you become
the creator of everything after you know
yourself and accept yourself how do you
be the creator it's kind of a long story
ooh what we could do another couple of
minutes to see if someone else asked
question let us know if you have any
questions guys I'm actually getting into
like this experience of like just being
watched by strangers without even
questions I think what's happening all
the time I feel like I'm in a shower
like I feel like I'm being showered by
public energy okay thanks for the
comment of price and pride
he he says he's totally asked me tonight
this is true this is true if you tuned
in like 15 minutes ago we were rapping
yeah that was a little less ASPI yeah
thanks for Iceland pride yeah 15 minutes
ago we were rapping and that if you
really wanted to get into something that
was a little more ass beat
check out the interview that already did
with Alex Kate chef Alex kitchen is in
Asian man who has the most answers on
Quora the question and answer site most
questions is really smart thanks for
tuning in everyone we have more viewers
if you guys have any questions for ori
he's fielding questions around growth
spirituality evolution healing ask the
way he is yours I'm yours
where he'd be so good if for uh that's
like a sales commercial and you can get
this look at that look at that span oh
thanks for tuning in everyone ask away
ask away how many viewers you got four
four all right good call this is a party
as a party I can totally feel it like I
feel you know you guys is presence but I
just feel like I'm in like a nice tank
being like monitor six people watching
guys sadek's people thanks for tuning in
this is extraordinary that's got to be
the record for tonight let us let us
know it is let us know your questions
aureus fielding questions around
spirituality growth healing evolution
consciousness let us know your questions
thanks for tuning in Alan we're so ready
for investment just today Jeff levy a
was on the show and was just like some
things are just not for venture which is
a very interesting point donations
patrons philanthropy all different
styles of funding methods we are ready
for your micro investments as viewers
and the big dog investments this is fun
yo if you look at my hands let me zoom
on it hold on alright alright I'm gonna
go ahead hold it up you can see that
it's like foot towards the camera that
faces you yeah you can see that it's it
kind of changes quickly but you can see
that it's like hold it in position so
that I guess I'm on it there you go okay
what are you trying to show them
kind of like blood infused mixture of
like red and white yes yeah it kind of
goes away but it's but anyway that
happens when I'm like open to all the
energies in the space even if they're
psychic in non-local hmm it's always
interesting when people choose to watch
and not submit questions okay let's hope
you're watching that you know it's also
just bless us please it's also important
to write AMA an evening for questions
AMA ask me anything I guess I guess I
have to build a rep yeah I did I did a
little bit of that too and it and it
helped people were definitely not
watching my AMAs when I started and even
now people really still don't really
watch my am ace that much but we had a
pretty decent one on the nature of
reality recently Connor crafts hello
thank you for your comment Connor
acidity and alkalinity cognition what is
a factor that agitates you or makes it
difficult to be on level with others hmm
that sounds like two questions yeah
let's start with that for some acidity
and alkalinity , cognition question mark
yeah
sounds like an interesting piece of the
health and performance puzzle I know wim
hof like the Iceman has like his whole
breathing in cold shower and mind
control methods that play with that kind
of blood chemistry and get in practice
getting you really alkaline and stuff
and then I like the second part of the
question because feels more relevant
to my life currently yep which was what
is a factor that agitates you or makes
it difficult to be on level with others
for me it's like this sense of like
reluctance to connect you know like just
getting the chance to connect with
people because I feel like our readiness
to to connect but uh but everybody is in
their worlds in their busy world then I
feel a little bit free from a lot of
like I feel kind of free from a lot of
what people are occupied by yup
mentally these days and so sometimes
it's hard to connect with people even
though I feel so so much space to offer
I feel like there's so much presence
here to to bring so that's my personal
answer to your question I don't know how
common it is in other words Ori is ready
for students and it and he sees other
people that are consumed with other
things that could potentially use what
he has to offer as a gift and he's ready
for students what about it making it
difficult to be on level with others
what's a factor that makes it difficult
to be on level with others yeah people
are wounded
everybody has their kind of eggshells
right like a lot of people these days
are kind of walking around on eggshells
where we can be easily like triggered
emotionally by things and so it's hard
to be
like if you if you really like
integrated within yourself then it can
be hard to be on level with people who
aren't what do you think Alan yeah and
also then go above you so like what do
like Sadhguru or Banting your and your
other role models what do they have that
makes it hard for you to be on level
with them they have a following they
have a place in the world they have a
structure around them and and so that
makes it harder to be on level with them
in one sense like for example banty no
Massaro the second guy Alan just
mentioned is finally coming to Las Vegas
which is driving distance from us it's
like a nine-hour drive he's coming in
Las Vegas for like a little retreat but
it's six thousand dollars a person so
that makes it difficult for me to be on
level with Benteen yo but uh but but my
sense is that people like him inside
guru are very level II in the sense that
if I did get ahold of them if I did get
to be with them that they would be
lovely and have that makeup
[Music]
I wonder how long ago was that like been
Tino was kind of like in your place of
wanting to put together the
infrastructure around him and what he
did to do that and how you can do it as
well yeah it sounds like like 10 years
ago or something he had some big
awakenings in India and then he came to
us and was like really just captivating
and like everybody just wanted to sit
around him and listen and that his like
vibration was really high and it was
like palpable so that's kind of cool
yeah yeah that's a big key is that can
you be that captivating that uh that
people want to be around you yeah and be
palpable enough with the way you're
communicating it like Alex was talking
about today yeah hey guys do you have
any other questions for Horry we would
love to hear from you let us know what
questions you have things for the last
couple comments and Connor thanks for
that last question again I love
questions these are my question
receiving hands
that's interesting that a banty neo had
spiritual awakenings in India do you
know do you know anything else about
that ten years ago and what that was
like and what he talks about regarding
it I know that they were very
enlightenment oriented and then you know
like enlightenment and he would talk
about like the space that's always here
and like give pointers toward it and
things yeah and then so he came to the
u.s. and then and then kind of focused
on that but then after a couple years
his focus became empowerment oriented so
he kind of has these two sides to
spiritual teaching like enlightenment
empowerment enlightenment and
empowerment so then in Colorado he spent
a chunk of years with more of an
empowerment focus like Law of Attraction
he would talk about and like manifesting
your dream life and like creating your
dream life and like personal development
like that sort of stuff and then after
that he ended up in Sedona Arizona back
on the Enlightenment side and he opened
a self-realization school where they'd
have meetings once a week and talk about
self-realization which is like
enlightenment I think and so and ever
since he's been more in the
Enlightenment side again but he was just
a great great incredible teacher
definitely one of my favorite and most
influential here on planet earth and I
just I love how how high his vibration
is if he will yeah let's get a let's
find our way to get into that
networking event 2 we have a question
from a price and pride any anecdotes on
whether being ultra spiritual leads to a
life of solitude slash disconnection
thanks for the question that's a great
question I guess it's up to you I guess
it's up to you
you know like I have had some awakenings
where it feels like I could go to the
middle of nowhere and my psychology
could survive like it feels like there's
it feels like I have that in me tattoo
but then like I feel so called I mean
you could say it's because of my Karma
you could say it's because of my family
relationships my karma and stuff but for
whatever reason I totally still feel a
call to do some work here in the world
super in the world the most in the world
like I want to bring like the most
enlightened consciousness right into the
heart of like leadership in like
influencers in like systems in
hierarchies so I I would say that it's
up to you and like for me personally I'm
in a phase where it's very worldly and
ultimately I could see myself wanting
most to kind of like have a house with
no one in it and like maybe even like
once a week just like go down and be
with some community for health reasons
and stuff so great question thanks and
I've thought of that as well
one of the good things about that style
of being alone for periods of time is
that it enables you to deeply reflect on
your purpose in the world if you're not
saturating that time with like consuming
content well you could do that even if
you live in the quote/unquote matrix you
know after the workday or whatever in
the evening you can lie on your bed
without your journal or phone and start
writing about what happened that day
that meant something to you however
smaller big and just processing each day
in transforming and becoming a new
person each day a more crystallized
expression of yourself a more integrated
soul and so maybe not that that's what I
did so maybe for some people it's best
to kind of get away on a meditation
retreat or to be secluded to be in
nature but maybe for others all you
really need is a closed door to your
room to kind of be in your own aura for
a while and to get in touch you know to
journal there or to be with your
thoughts or however you like to do it
yeah
almost certainly by doing that you know
yourself better yes and we usually enter
into friend networks when we're in our
school days growing up and then towards
our end of our 20s we kind of like an
even mid-20s we kind of branch maybe a
little bit more towards our specific
interests and you can kind of feel
people falling off of your friend group
and a couple people falling into your
friend group that are new and but the
more that you become more deeply
connected to yourself and your divine
purpose usually the more you don't need
to go to bars and you don't need to go
to clubs and mmhmm yeah
the raddest thing to try is to like
meditate in a bar or club with your eyes
open yeah I think that's I think that's
big for people who are have already kind
of spent some time meditating and stuff
on their own I think the next frontier
for creating the next world would be to
become meditative in social situations
I'm so happy that you said that and we
got into that point right now because
that's what you have taught me to double
and triple down on even though before it
was more people still today call it like
people watching but there's still a
level deeper than people watching
being I feel a big presence here yeah go
ahead
yeah yeah me too but right when you got
into that point I felt the presence it
is the next level when you've done a lot
of meditation the next level is to bring
your meditative self to the world and to
the especially the most matrix II parts
of the world and see what as already
says how it feels like holding space in
those settings yeah yes and then when
you're meditative and that's your
disposition there's no other exciting
thing to do but be a mirror and a
balancing agent for social situations
and so that can look vibrant and dynamic
and then that can look meditative but
it's just this intuitive navigation of
balancing the energy of the room or the
equation what does that mean though for
when you are in that like bar and you're
trying to hold space there what does
being a mirror and balancing agent mean
like you mean like like when give us an
example of like when something goes down
and how you're a mirror or a balancing
agent let us know if you guys have any
questions for or II love to hear from
you
yeah an example so someone gets loud and
then you answer quietly or someone or
the room feels dead and then you kind of
like inject some vibrancy into it
skillfully so it's an intuitive it's a
sensing thing it's it's like
precognitive it's not thought out
necessarily so that's an interesting
example so for the rooms quiet you
inject vibrancy if the room is vibrant
you inject silence yeah I don't know but
the thing is like who's the one being
intuitive and and how integrated is he
you know like how much of his pain has
he felt and loved yeah
you keep coming back to that point about
feeling and loving your own pain so each
of us have that and it needs to be loved
excuse me yeah yeah I like this presence
that I'm feeling like I don't know who
or what it is but I feel like we're in
cool company now like I feel like what
we're doing matters it picks up in the
last 25 minutes just great
I also fill in some heart heart opening
it's good stuff thanks for tuning in
everyone let us know what questions you
have yes Ori uh-huh
please do
this is also
interesting because
bringing the meditative self out into
the world becomes its own
learning a little part of your learning
simulation and there's just a constant
iteration process on becoming better and
better at it like I want to share this
story because you you know you really
inspired me to do it but just seeing the
way that Ori participates at events
versus the way that I do you know I'm
the guy running around events trying to
network with people find who the right
people are to network with get connected
to them do collaborations cross
pollinate networks help each other
creatively execute and then you know Ori
is at these events doing that rarely and
then most of the time just holding space
for the place so he's mostly you know
standing or sitting and it's in silence
usually with his eyes open and engaging
with the energy of the of the of the
space and so he started inspiring me to
do exactly that and so then I found
myself doing that and very fascinating
things started happening and maybe we'll
get to the story but Roth's Grover hey
Ross thanks for commenting we really
appreciate you being a frequent of you
or in comments or of the show Rollo yeah
good to see you in there Ross's question
what are your thoughts on a matrix mind
grappling the idea of spiritual
enlightenment it can be difficult
explaining the uniqueness of one's own
path without the Pathfinder copying and
pasting you that's the Pathfinder
copying and pasting here
as in like the matrix is the one that's
doing the copying and pasting for
people's past like putting them in the
machinery and then the idea of trying to
spiritually enlighten this here we read
that yeah what are your thoughts on a
matrix mind grappling the idea of
spiritual enlightenment it can be
difficult explaining the uniqueness of
one's own path without the Pathfinder
copying and pasting you can you read it
one more time yeah what are your
thoughts on a matrix mind grappling the
idea of spiritual enlightenment it can
be difficult explaining the uniqueness
of one's own path without the Pathfinder
copying and pasting you I think I I
think I understand what's being asked
and if so my thoughts are that I can
relate I can totally relate
we're co-creating each other and so you
can be the most enlightened soul but
walk into our room with certain minds
and you're going to be co-created in a
certain way and so that can be
disheartening at times but it can also
be an epic navigation to integrate the
minds of of the quote unquote matrix and
kind of unlock their unique hearts and
approvals and just becoming that much
more purified and connected
and so that can be an interesting
journey to try to kind of land in the
hearts of all people in the hearts of
the matrix and change it from inside out
you know to be in the world but not of
it as they say not of this world but not
in it like certain people thank you for
your question Ross yeah he says I love
that idea
and once you say spiritual they
sometimes copy your insight some are so
copy and paste that it's hard to look
inside yes absolutely
and so you got to be the real deal and
just exemplify it and the ones who are
meant to recognize it will and that's
fulfilling like on a on a bell curve of
people that are at orys students it
would be people that are already like
have a taste of spiritual enlightenment
yeah even more so than putting it that
way I love earnestness and qualities
like readiness and even fed-up ness and
love and well intentions and realness
and rawness and honesty it's self
inquiry so these are qualities I love
even more than like quote unquote awake
people whose people whose pupils are big
and like may have transcended themselves
in a certain way but I love I love like
some of those qualities I listed you
know sometimes you'll find just quote
unquote normal people in the real world
but
of they give you a good feeling you know
that just feels like a good guy and so
there's different versions of spiritual
people yeah that book that's great or a
earnestness readiness fed-up nest those
are great qualities to look for in
students devotion yeah I would rather
have a quote-unquote date with a devoted
person than anyone else like no matter
how famous or whatever
what are they devoted to
themselves
themselves their process life life's
process the highest beauty humans parts
God if you will
divinity truth
excellent yeah thanks for those
questions Ross keep it up everyone
always catching some fire keep it up
guys another comment from Ross I wish we
could have City Collective spiritual
sit-downs to heal from a world we
created too fast if everyone knew we
could heal before our tech is too
contaminated city collective sit-downs
calling it in city collective sit-downs
city collective spiritual sit-downs
before our tech is too contaminated what
would inspire a movement
what would pull people toward this what
captivates in truth
price and price has drugs and Ross
Grover says it's tricky
no drugs it's so interesting that those
two comments are literally the right
hand path left hand path debate right
hand path being no drugs and left hand
path being drugs do whatever you need to
re commune with God and the infinite
Ross says people's minds aren't strong
enough
yes
Ross says minds are too fragile
sounds like Ross
is really do you want to try and hold
some space for Ross well I'm just
sharing that I if if you're still here -
Ross my sense is that you may be as I
have been really impacted by the
landscape you find yourself in and you
know you've mentioned the matrix and
people's minds and the strength of them
and uh I I don't know
I wonder what emotion is there in your
nervous system around it I wonder if
there's resentment I wonder if there's
frustration I wonder if there is hurt I
wonder if there's grief I wonder if
there is rage and whatever it is I
wonder if it can be felt and breathed
through and connected with
yeah that was great Ross let us know if
any of those things resonate with you if
if if there's any resentment or hurt or
rage about the world and if this can be
felt by you and be breathe through
connected with he says rolling on the
floor laughing human history is filled
with all of those emotions oh yeah we
collective energies yeah totally worried
yesterday told me that I'm trudging
through a wasteland
Ross says no rage okay
unless it's swallowed yeah I had a I had
a great pivotal therapist a few years
ago who told me that I was swallowing my
anger and I was a college basketball
player at the time and I kind of had
this coming-out party with my anger
where I like kind of confronted my coach
in front of the whole team and it was
pretty epic and it felt really good
afterward in it and it resolved in a
beautiful way in front of everyone but
I'm not saying that's the case for
everyone I was kind of like this super I
was just like really nice and stuff and
so I was swallowing my anger I was
scared to get angry I was scared of what
I could be like when I was angry but
anger is such an intense energy that it
can clog us up if it's not if it doesn't
move it's one of the emotions and it
makes us whole to have a relationship
with it
Ross says it's like toddlers on a
playground at recess the price and pride
says don't eat your feelings ory thank
you yeah I try not to
I love the opposite of eating my
feelings
because it's healthy and it leaves a
green footprint you know everyone that
we think is in a hole usually they're in
some sort of pain and so when we feel
our emotions when we process our
emotions doesn't have to be with people
or it can be then in my opinion our
footprint becomes greener because the
way we can show up in the world is a
little more spacious loving patient
sharp etc can I get an amen amen
I'm just swimming in these public
energies as people online and it's kind
of cool
I can feel it I feel like I've taken
like a mud shower if you look at my
hands you'll see that they're infused
with
blood because I'm sensing it all
well let us know if you guys have any
more questions I want to back to editing
that video
Roth says I can't hold feelings they
warp my quiet mind can hold feelings
they warp my quiet mind everyone has a
unique disposition and healthy balance
ultimately if you want to embody
enlightenment and then become a
meditative vessel then we want to
process all our emotions but maybe this
is your current homeostasis sometimes we
do a certain amount of emotional work
and then the next step is we have these
emotions that are actually tied to
relationships and so they can't move in
a effective way without addressing a
relationship and then maybe there's a
timing for that in your life about when
it should happen so food for thought
los says awesome sit down guys by the
way thanks for us great really yeah
thanks for joining us brother thank you
I like that last point on emotions being
tied to relationships it's a very
interesting one too it's a very complex
web that we're immersed in and to know
how to navigate it it's very very
important yeah you wanna um tinkle
tinkle time night guys thanks to the
blue light spiritual toning that Ross
that was price and pride Ross's yes
thanks guys yeah good night
thanks so much we really appreciate you
tuning in you want to rap on that high
note we can but just noticing that it
sounds like after like an hour we start
to catch a flow and in some dialogue
going
some a song yeah so maybe in the future
we can plan for that yeah yeah cuz after
25 we didn't have too much after 50 we
had a decent amount and now it's dropped
back down so with more engaging we are
also a little more yeah people all right
cool thanks Alan this was fun and thank
you to the people who participated this
is in a corn this is a small taste of
what's coming hopefully so thank you for
being a part of it yes and let us know
your thoughts in the comments below on
the points that or he was sharing and
that you guys were asking Ross also says
love you guys please keep these up so
nice of you
Thank You Ross
you - thank you so much Ross where you
were you coming from were you located
we're in Silicon Valley in the San
Francisco Bay Area in California
USA
our boy Ross's from Columbus Ohio mmm
Columbus Ohio yeah the oddest city in
the world I love it thanks for tuning in
Ross thanks for letting us we'll know
where you're coming from alright guys
thanks so much again and if you find
these to be important just find our but
our contribution buttons below you can
join us for even just the little amounts
thanks everyone thank you fellers and
does that include women sisters sisters
too yeah